I'm on set with Dress Barn come watch me
do my thing
when all the eyes are on you and
everybody's staring at you and you're
thinking okay I can't trip I'm wearing
this amazing outfit and everybody in the
world is staring at me because not only
is it everybody here but it's cameras
it's video it's and you get this energy
and you're like I have to pull it
together work and I channel my own
example and I just go and I give you
hips I give you sway and I give you I
give you the look and I take it I take
it down the runway and I take it back
and when I get back on the other side of
the runway I'm like that was amazing I'm
so freaked out but I want to do it again
and you can't because it's over because
runway shows are only ten minutes my
favorite part of the shoe is honestly I
like being on set I like dancing on set
everybody says how do you know how to
model how did you learn how to model
I actually just didn't learn I just
started dancing I saw different girls in
the pages of Vogue and glamour and Elle
and it always kind of looked like they
had a motion to their body and that's
exactly what I want it to look like in a
lot of my photos so I just have dancing
but I always ensure that my face is on
fleek there's never a moment where I'm
looking like
you know you have to be in touch with
every single part of your body so I know
where everything is I know what
everything is moving and I can move
almost every single muscle in my face
for every photo shoot I have to be ready
because my agent will call me the night
before and say hey you're flying out to
Paris tomorrow morning to shoot a photo
shoot for whatever magazine so I take
care of my body all the time I'm a
foodie and I love to eat but I also want
to make sure that it's clean
I will pig out on a burger and fries
every once in a while I am not mad at
that
but I'm always I offer
I think social media has everything to
do with anybody's brand if you're not on
social media and you have a brand then
then your brand I don't believe it's
going to be a successful social media
has also built a community for women
like me and women who are bigger than me
smaller than me who spot something or
ugly who thought that they were good
enough there's different hashtags that
you can follow and you can see other
women like you and one that I created
that I love and it's called beauty
beyond size and a lot of women
hashtag it in their photos of pictures
that they probably wouldn't have posted
if they didn't think that they had a
community that looked like them I do
consider myself a role model I think you
don't go into a job and and say I'm
going to be a role model today it kind
of just happens and I'm so happy to be a
role model for so many young women women
my age and even older women now who
haven't really truly loved the skin that
they're in who haven't loved the woman
that they look at in front of the mirror
and I'm happy to be a voice for them
you